in this video we try to understand one
of the most interesting
three-dimensional shapes it's called a
prism most people think of a prism as
something like this but have no idea
about its correct definition so let's
erase this and start with the definition
of a prism it's a three-dimensional
shape a three-dimensional shape that has
identical parallel ends and all flat
faces well it's the most confusing
definition ever identical parallel flat
there are just too many things so forget
the definition for now let's just look
at figures and understand prisms look at
this three-dimensional figure the most
important thing in topic of
three-dimensional shapes is visualizing
the shapes few of the lines are dotted
because those are the lines that cannot
be seen from this view look at the ends
of this figure it's a long figure with
two ends now let me color the two ends
for you this figure has two triangles at
its ends and it has three rectangles as
faces this one in the front one at the
back and one at the bottom now we look
at the definition it says that the ends
are identical and parallel they are
identical since both are triangles and
both the triangles are parallel to each
other the definition also says that all
its faces should be flat and in this
figure all faces are flat they are
rectangles this by the way is called a
triangular prism here's another
three-dimensional shape let me color its
ends we can see that it has two
rectangles as ends and they are also
parallel to each other and it has four
rectangles as faces one on the right
hand side one on the left hand side one
at the top and one at the bottom so all
its faces are flat this is called a
rectangular prism so if you noticed the
prisms are defined by its ends triangles
as its ends
triangular prism rectangles at its ends
rectangular prism look at the
rectangular prism does this shape remind
you of another three-dimensional shape
yes a rectangular prism is also a cuboid
now let's look at a few figures and
understand if their prisms are not
remember the definition identical
parallel ends and all flat surfaces
here's the first figure it's a part of a
pipe both the ends are circles and up
parallel to each other it means that
this figure has identical parallel ends
this figure has identical parallel ends
but has a curved surface hence it's not
a prism I want to emphasize there are
only two things that make a
three-dimensional shape a prism
identical and parallel ends and all its
phases flat here the ends are flat but
the surface is curved so it's not a
prism here's another figure first we
look at the ends
both are triangles and hence we can say
that this figure has identical ends but
wait they are not parallel the upper
triangle is slightly tilted so this
figure as well is not a prism now assume
we have a plane with a rectangle on it
if we project the rectangle upwards
equally from all sides we get a prism in
this figure we have projected all the
sides to the same height but what if we
do not project all the sides to equal
Heights if we do not project it equally
like in this figure we do not get a
prism this is not a prism as its ends
are not parallel